good
everybody it's good to be here Thank You
Seth Thank You Emily Thank You Perry can
you all hear me up there in the back
your audio is okay okay good so my might
ask for the afternoon is to talk a
little bit about the rationale for
applying DBT to adolescents I'm going to
give you a little bit of an update on
the research I'm going to talk about the
biosocial theory briefly i think i think
it's been covered pretty well today so
i'm going to power through that go over
a little bit of our DBT assumptions
targets and modes i'm going to show you
a video clip of me introducing DBT to a
16 year old young man I want to spend a
few minutes highlighting some of the
skills that Jill ratha sand I added to
our recently published skills manual for
teens and families and talk a little bit
about the adaptations of dbt for schools
and medical settings and then conclude
with some future directions so i know
when i see that year 1995 I definitely
am starting to feel older i my my
eyeglasses I'm going to start to need a
second pair for the reading and the
distance I'm just about at that point
but 20 years ago Jill rattus and I
started adapting DBT for suicidal multi
problem adolescents and we used Marsha
Linehan inclusion criteria which were
targeting adolescents who were suicidal
engaging in non-suicidal self-injury
having multiple problems multiple
diagnoses and where we started at
Montefiore Medical Center in the Bronx
the teens that we were seeing had about
two and a half at the time axis 1
disorders coupled with either borderline
personality features or the full
disorder itself and we there's been a
good number of trials that have been
done over these 20 years that have been
kind of quasi experimental studies and
open trials we finally published our
first randomized control trial last year
which i will show you momentarily which
I'm very pleased about but since over
that time there's been a lot of
adaptations of dbt for other populations
that are non borderline spectrum
non-suicidal including bipolar
adolescents disordered eating
adolescents
and also obviously adapted for different
populations and settings like impatient
residential like three East and McClain
and various other treatment settings the
thought about it though and we wrote a
chapter on this let a couple years ago
is that the common denominator among
these populations is that they have
trouble as far as we conceptualize it as
regulating emotions and regulating
behaviors so trans diagnostically we
think d BTW has applicability to variety
of populations it doesn't have to be
exclusively BPD or bipolar or any other
specific disorder and what I like about
it is the flexibility within disorders
to target using the principles and the
targets that I'm going to go over now
Carla is very modest but she published a
book and edited a book rather that I
think is a definitive handbook that
everybody who works with children
adolescents with BPD should own should
have in your personal library and your
office of course it's the handbook of
BPD in children adolescents and it
really addresses some a lot of
neurobiological issues but it also talks
about the existence of BPD in this age
group and a long time ago people would
scoff at me and my colleagues saying
there's no such thing as BPD before your
18th birthday and I think I'm preaching
to the choir here clearly those who us
who have worked with younger people
under the age of 18 who have suffered
before the age of 18 know that BPD does
exist before your 18th birthday and this
book has data to support that now from a
dbt perspective how do we conceptualize
borderline personality disorder you've
heard from Francesca you've heard from
many others we think about is a
pervasive disorder of the emotion
regulation system and as you all know
the nine criteria I'm not going to spend
a lot of time going over these criteria
but it is useful that the central
problem as far as we're concerned is
emotional dysregulation central problem
for BPD and from that the sequelae into
these other areas of dysregulation
are significant into the interpersonal
realm into the behavioral realm into the
sense of self realm and of course in the
cognitive realm so these five areas of
dysregulation as many of you know we re
labeled in layman's terms to have these
five primary problem areas that we talk
about and we introduce teens and
families to DBT we talk about well
Marsha Linehan original
conceptualization of confusion about
self with adults with BPD we've
broadened the term to include reduced
awareness and reduce focus many of the
kids that we work with often talk about
kind of being blindsided things just
come along they have no idea what
happened they just got upset before they
knew it their hands punching the wall
they're cursing and screaming and
slamming doors and they just didn't have
the awareness of the nascent stages of
the emotion or the action urge that led
to that problematic behavior the part of
it is increasing awareness of emotions
thoughts action urges and actions the
other part of it of course is mental
focus many of our clients have a lot of
trouble staying in this present moment
they're getting mentally and emotionally
hijacked from things that have been
problematic in their past and their kind
of sitting in class looking at their
math teacher but their mind is clearly
not on algebra they are they are often
going backwards into some painful things
that have happened in the past or lo and
behold they're drifting forwards
mentally and thinking about their accts
and SATs and oh my god i can't believe
it i'm going to fit i'm the lou terribly
blah blah blah blah blah so we want to
spend some time with these kids whether
they have ADHD depression anxiety
getting their mental camera lens back to
this present moment as it is and when it
drifts and it will as it does for all of
us and probably from any of you right
now at about three o'clock on a Friday
afternoon
you will notice the drift hopefully and
say what is Alex again yes what is Alex
saying and so yes you will try to
practice mindfulness during this next
hour that would be very good so we teach
mindfulness skills and many of you in
the audience are familiar with which is
teaching our kids and their parents how
to observe and describe non-judgmentally
what their experience is in this moment
with compassion so that is critical a
core skill that underlies the entire
treatment as many of you know who do DBT
we're going to repeat mindfulness
throughout the curriculum so mindfulness
then we'll teach distressed arms to deal
with impulsivity then we'll go back to
mindfulness and teach emotion regulation
skills to deal with emotional
dysregulation then we'll go back to
mindfulness and teach interpersonal
effectiveness to deal with the
interpersonal problems now after a bunch
of years of doing this standard DBT
package that Marsha Linehan developed
Jill and I realized that there were a
lot of teenager and family dilemmas that
were not sufficiently being addressed in
the standard DBT package so we adapted
some and develop some new skills called
walking the middle path skills to
address some of what many of you in the
audience probably know is intense
polarized states between teen and a
parent between one parent and the other
parent about how to manage this
particular adolescent between therapists
and teenagers between therapists and the
parents of those teenagers so when
emotions get high and intense so goes
the behavior so goes the responses and
and so goes to thinking processing as
you've heard very eloquently presented
today so we wanted to kind of teach and
highlight for these families and the
kids how they get non dialectical is
another way to describe it in their
thinking or a hyper mentalizing one
might say if Carla would say right where
you're kind of extreme responses to the
present moment and very very
black-and-white varied economists you're
right I'm wrong I'm right you're wrong
I'm good I'm bad I'm silly no I'm
serious and how do you find a middle
path between this truth and this truth
and kind of developing a synthesis
between what is often polarized stances
for some of the fan
they go from excessive leniency and
tolerance of some extreme things that
are happening and all of a sudden the
pendulum swings once the kid goes up
crosses a certain threshold that's it
you're grounded you're not seeing any
electronics you're not going out for the
next six months how's that working for
you not so well right so so you go from
excessive leniency to authoritarian
control and the middle path from a
parenting perspective is come on guys
what's the middle path between
excessively NC and authoritarian control
authoritative parenting kind of having
some structure some limits but having
some flexibility and not kind of going
off the deep end on the parenting end
either so there's multiple perspective
some of the families we work with
pathologized normative behavior and
normalize what we think is pathological
behavior and I can validate the families
in here who are struggling with that
because your parental compass is kind of
on its dial spinning around because you
don't know what is normative anymore I
don't know what normative is so you need
some advice and guidance as to what are
some typical adolescent behaviors and
those change developmentally from 12 to
14 to 16 18 but we want to work with the
families help them find some from an
educational perspective and some
emotional perspective what some balanced
ways of approaching some of these
situations so that's one aspect of the
teenager family dilemma is another thing
that clearly has been highlighted today
is this idea of invalidation and EBT we
talked about the invalid dating
environment and when I first learned
about this 20 years ago and I know Perry
and Cindy Sanderson we're kind of
instrumental in teaching Jill and myself
a little bit about DBT at the at the
early stages we were like we're going to
talk to these families about them being
an invalidating environment
I mean I better start taking cover right
now they're going to feel blamed and
I've occurred to us over time that it's
just describing problematic behavior
which I engage in Jill engages in kids
engage in parents engage in and you know
who else engages is that teachers
medical doctors and a whole host of
other people not just the families and
so once we kind of you know stick away
the blame aspect of it as we interpreted
it and just described it as a
problematic behavior that many of us
engage in if we're not careful hey we
can just call what it is and work on
better validation so we're going to
teach you validation skills and thirdly
is poor contingency management turns out
when you get emotional and I'm a parent
myself if I get dysregulated I
definitely want to throw down the
gauntlet and and throw down some major
consequences and as you heard from
Francesca earlier when you hear the you
know jibber jabbering and escalating
escalating I can tolerate for a little
while but when as soon as I heard hear
my daughter a son screaming at the other
one and yelling then I stopped my
emailing and I move over and I say hey
stop that and I do exactly what
Francesca instructs people not to do
thank you for the early morning lesson
so what we are working on is trying to
teach the teens and the parents in this
case effective parenting management you
heard it being done with the kids and of
course with adolescents it's just as
critical how'd it and what we're missing
is the positive reinforcement the
natural reinforcements of praise catch
them being good catch them being good
and when you're depleted and you're
exhausted and you're doing all kinds of
stuff to come just stay afloat as a
parent it is not easy to kind of catch
them being good right it's hard so it
does require what skill to be able to
catch them being good you have to be
mindful you have to be noticing you have
to be out of your head and be aware of
what's happening around you to catch
them be good and change that dynamic we
got to talk about extinction we got to
talk about effective punishment not
ineffective punishment right so there's
all
parenting work we do on kind of
contingency management so that's the
walking the middle path skills oh my god
this is this is service with a smile i
ordered this about two hours ago and
look at it now I got Emily this is
delicious coffee thank you wow that's
great okay yeah grind the beans yeah
that's good yeah I need that mid
afternoon you know you guys know I'm
talking about that mid-afternoon low
especially on a friday boy you need that
ok so why so why DB T for teens i'm
about to share with you some of the data
of the randomized trial but for many
years we've had a quasi-experimental and
open data which was promising the
biosocial theory which many of you know
about if you have questions i can i can
talk more about it but it really treats
the therapist treats the family treats
the child in the sense of better having
a more empathic compassionate
understanding of how they got to be this
way and when i presented the bio social
theory to some kids over the years and
teenagers that is I see tears rolling
down their face because something
finally makes sense as to why how they
got to be here that I'm wired in a
different kind of way in some ways and
and as we heard this morning it's not
all bad right having some emotional
sensitivity is it can be a wonderful
characteristic if you can manage it and
doesn't kind of get the best of you so
that and then the environment that is
invalidating whether it be cyber
bullying and peer bullying from your
peers and stuff at home and your coaches
and your teachers right if that's
pervasive over time you're wired to be
this way it makes sense that you have a
more emotional dysregulation so when you
can present this and teach this to the
child or adolescent or young adult or
adult with BPD there's a whole new found
appreciation and understanding and it
really is validating to learn the theory
themselves now d BTW is skills bait and
by the way the bio social theory of
course informs the treatment so if we
understand that they're wired to be more
emotionally vulnerable sensitive and we
also understand their skills deficient
there's a lot of sense of people out in
the world who have some coping skills
and don't end up having borderline
borderline presentations but those who
have skills sent emotional sensitivity
emotional reactivity slow return to
baseline coupled with significant
deficits and emotion regulation skills
that's the recipe coupled with
invalidating environment that leads to
BPD and emotion dysregulation so we know
that we have to teach them emotion
regulation skills to deal with that
deficit from a validating environment
standpoint it's clear as day to me that
we have to teach more about validation
and we had this misconception early on
when we started developing this
treatment 20 years ago oh yeah we'll
just put the parents and skills group
they'll come they'll do one rotation and
well and the kids will have individual
therapy and that'll be that and then it
finally occurred to us after that not
working as well as we had hoped that we
actually have to work with the families
in addition to them learning the skills
so it's one thing to learn the skill
acquire the skill it's another thing to
practice in a family session working
together ironing out all those glitches
that inevitably will come up what I like
about DBT for adolescents is really
skills-based and they talk about the
skills deficits and kids are used to
learning and practicing and rehearsing
and therefore we're going to do a lot of
that with them and in DB t is this
multimodal nature of treatment that
affords us various entry points into
their lives I can't tell you what a
pleasure it is for me to see some of my
individual clients who also i get to see
in our multifamily skills group and i
get to see how the interface with their
peers their families so i have a whole
new appreciation for them in a different
social context so there's a lot of value
and then i speak to them after hours and
give them coaching so there's these
different ways of kind of working with
them so I'll going to give you a little
bit of an update on where we are in the
adolescent DBT randomized trials state
of the union so a friend Tina Goldstein
out at University of Pittsburgh is
underway in a randomized trial looking
at DB T versus care as usual six-month
trial for bipolar disorder and
suicidality and that's underway so I
don't have any more data to share with
you but she's published some nice open
trials and some smaller
trials which are very promising in
reducing suicidal behavior and reducing
depressive and manic symptomatology and
improving family functioning and she's
also demonstrated high feasibility
meaning that the families really find it
to be a useful and an acceptable and
tolerable intervention over those six
months and just so you know with the
bipolar adolescents they do
single-family skills training they don't
put them in a group Marsha Linehan Liz
McCauley Jonas are now and Michelle
Burke at University of Washington
Seattle as well as UCLA have a large
scale it's called care study there
they're nearing the end of their study
and that's a dbt compared to supportive
psychotherapy and manualized treatment
so they have it's manualized cyclic
control condition and they're looking at
highly suicidal adolescents over that
six-month window and and the first one
number one is study conducted that we
just published this out coming from
University of Oslo in Norway large melon
is the principal investigator and it's a
16 week DBT versus enhanced usual care
and and here's the reference it was
published in the orange journal American
Academy of Child and Adolescent
Psychiatry for a dbt for recent and
repeated self-harming behaviors and we
compared the control condition was
enhanced usual care and enhance shoes
will care in Norway while usual care in
Norway is CBT or psychodynamic and what
was enhanced about it was that the kids
and then therapists in both conditions
got training in what's called a you ramp
anybody know what the you ramp is that's
the University of Washington risk
assessment management protocol and and
Marsha Linehan and her colleagues in
Seattle developed this it's a very it
kind of has all the suicide risk factors
and then it tells you at a certain point
what how to kind of manage it if you
want to get it online you can go to the
University of Washington and download it
for free so basically they got trained
in how to assess and manage high suicide
risk now most people in the community
are not getting that training as part of
their usual care right most of most of
the therapist so don't have that
training in addition
the enhanced usual care condition was
also notified anytime a patient reported
to the research Assessors at every 48
weeks whether they had an increased risk
for suicide the research assessment team
would notify the therapists that their
patient was having more suicidality so
there were a lot more protections put
into place to make sure when working
with his suicidal population that we did
everything we could to kind of equalize
or calibrate at least the risk
assessment piece of things and the
treatment was delivered to five clinics
around outpatient clinics nozzle Norway
so like I said it was a randomized trial
blinded pre-post follow-up and we had
baseline 16 weeks and which was really
kind of into treatment we're coming at
the end of the one year post-treatment
follow-up which we're going to publish
soon and then the two year
post-treatment and only a nozzle in
Norway can you get funding for a 10-year
follow-up you got to have a lot more oil
than we do to be able to get funding
federal funding for that so the patients
who received EBT compared to enhance
usual care had significantly stronger
reductions the number of self-harm
episodes stronger decline of suicidal
ideation stronger reductions in
interviewer rated depressive symptoms
stronger reductions in hopelessness and
stronger reductions in borderline
symptoms so again this is a 16-week
outcome and we felt that that was I mean
with the sample did I say about 77
subjects split between the two
conditions so it didn't have a huge
sample size but good enough to find some
nice effect sizes and significant
outcomes so if there's questions about
this I mean I'm sure there will answer
those in a while all right I already
talked about the biosocial theory I
don't need to go over this unless
there's questions I'm going to skip it
because many people have heard extension
extensive conversations about biosocial
so I'm going to power through these
slides suffice it to say though that I
was just spent the last two days working
with teachers educators in
and local public schools and I spent a
lot of time with them teaching them the
bio social theory because some of these
very well-meaning teachers have this
idea of you know validation means
encouragement and praise and they don't
fully appreciate the function of
validation and so we did a lot of role
playing with them and we kind of
introduced the whole bio social theory
so they had I think engendering a lot
more compassion for the for the sum of
their motioning disregulated students
that are otherwise they feel personally
don't like them and they over
personalize the students behavior as an
attack on them as teachers and so we had
we did some good work and they really
want to have their other teachers who
are not present for the for the training
to learn about this too because there's
just not a lot of education for teachers
about understanding these mental health
types of issues and sensitive
emotionally reactive kids and what to do
so validation in and of itself we know
can help if it's done well can reduce
emotional dysregulation and some of the
kids were working with so many of you
here know about the structure of the
deep of dbt with adolescents but wanted
just to highlight that when we
introduced DBT to families and teenagers
we talked about these assumptions that
we think are useful if DBT is going to
take some take some let me make some
gains in DB T so the first one I
typically ask the most disgruntled
parent in the multifamily group do you
think you can you read number one mr.
Smith and he says well people are doing
the best they can and now realized this
is four or five teenagers and their
parent or parents sitting around a large
conference table and I again I
specifically selected I thought the
parent who was most having the most
difficulty and and usually that parents
about to embark on a diatribe about how
that's the most ridiculous statement
they've ever seen because how could
Jessica be doing the best she can she's
here she's been hospitalized you know
we're thinking about sending her a
wilderness treatment it's impossible
she's doing the best she can so I say
mr. Smith when Jessica was dreaming up
for adolescence a few years ago do you
think she was imagining being here with
you and me on a Wednesday night and a
multifamily skills group talking about
this stuff and
having to deal with a lot of the stuff
she's dealing with at school at home
this was not her her plan if she could
effectively manage some of her emotions
and impulses differently don't you think
she would be he's like I guess so I
guess yeah guess so and by definition
than I think she must be doing the best
she can in this moment will you give me
that much okay now what about number two
people need to do better try harder be
more motivated to change uh-huh yes mr.
Smith's back on board that definitely
that one that one's definitely true so I
want to introduce this cord I elective
DBT mr. Smith Jessica in this moment I
have to believe is doing the best she
can because if she would do better she
would and by the way mr. Smith you as
the dad I have no doubt you're doing the
best you can with your daughter and I
have to believe that some areas that you
yourself might be able to improve in to
be more effective parents that possibly
true mr. Smith just go with me on that
is that true okay and by the way you're
me your friendly neighborhood skills
trainer I'm doing the best I can in this
moment but I have no doubt I skipped
over some biosocial slides that I feel
badly about now and and I want to hit
some of that more next time so but I
think universally speaking we're all
doing the best we can in this moment on
the one hand and we need to do better be
more effective and try harder and I
think that's the core dialectic of dbt
and if you can hold these two truths
that seem like opposites at the same
time you're now understanding this first
constructed of dialectics I go through
some of these other assumptions that
people want to improve that teens and
families must learn and practice new
behaviors in all the different
situations in their lives so this this
gets back to this skills deficit notion
which i think you know there's
definitely a lot of similarities between
mental ization DBT and there's some
differences and one of them is this this
own notion of a skills deficit that
requires learning new skills and
practicing and sending them out and
giving them coaching and I tell them
when I teach in the skills group and let
we can all have a good time in here and
Wednesday nice and laugh and so on and
learn some new stuff but unless you
practice this stuff with meaning and
find that this is a necessary thing for
you to build a life worth living I'm
afraid this may be you know could be a
waste of time and I
want to do that people may not have
caused all their own problems but they
have to solve them anyway so this again
[ __ ] does happen there's no doubt about
it in our lives and you know whether it
be divorces or deaths or moves or having
a chronic medical illness that you can't
or chronic mental health condition
there's all kinds of things that happen
that you cannot necessarily change and
yet this is the cards you were dealt and
how are you going to deal with it things
happen and you have to learn how to the
skills to cope with it and of course the
lives of emotionally distressed teens
are and families or painful as they are
currently being lived now when we talk
about individual therapy and EBT we
think of a stages of treatment approach
and one of the things that I think
beginning DBT therapist missed kind of
rushed to do is rush to work on you know
severe behavioral problems and the
clients themselves whether it be teens
or adults say hey let's go we got a lot
of stuff going on here some of them I
need help and sometimes though we we
skip over what I think is a critical
point which is the pretreatment stage of
treatment and then that stage I want to
kind of assess I want to build rapport I
want to have trust I want to kind of
kind of gauge where they're at and
understand that they have agreement on
some goals before i move the train out
of the station and work on some of the
more significant life problems that
they're coming and presenting with so i
just want to remind those of the
clinicians in the room they just because
they show up to your office that they're
depressed suicidal borderline spectrum
disordered eating and what substance
abuse problems that's that's a lot going
on yes and unless they've agreed to work
on some of these things i wouldn't start
moving in them into skills group and
working on treatment if you will until
they've had some agreement now of course
pre treatment is treatment right getting
commitment motivation agreement on goals
but i think there's there's i see where
a lot of times DBT fails is they're
rushing them into skills group because
they're here and there have a lot going
on and I'm anxious as a therapist so
let's just put them in the treatment
program and that's
that's a mistake and I want you to be
careful about the other thing just to
remind folks is that I think we
sometimes if people have trauma
histories and they want to have
treatment for their trauma but there's
still self injuring they're still
binging and purging they're still
abusing drugs from a stage theory that
would fall under stage 2 or level to
write in terms of helping process past
emotional trauma and there's a time and
a place for that but it's not until they
have acquired some skills in some
capacity for emotion regulation in some
distress before we kind of usher them
into trauma focused treatment okay so
this is a kind of a DVT is is a
principle-based treatment and it has
certain structure to the targets and if
you visualize a treatment target
hierarchy we're obviously trying to
decrease life threatening behavior first
and foremost therapy and differing
behavior now who engages in therapy and
different behavior the client or the
teenager in this case could come late
not do their diary card not call me for
coaching when they need to the family
couldn't could engage in therapy and for
any behavior they meet maybe saying okay
Johnny this is your treatment this is
your show will drop you off if you know
if you're lucky but you know sometimes
that family does come in full throttle
let's do this and they're they're kind
of so excited sometimes it's also
therapy and it for him because anything
that good from a parental perspective
has to be terrible from a teenager
perspective so I tell the parents tone
it down a lil bit don't don't talk it up
so much because not going to scare them
off so there is a little bit that but
then sometimes the families could be not
necessarily as as eager I've seen a lot
of the families in the Bronx they have
there they have so much to manage on
their plate they're single parents you
know poverty they have trouble getting
in at all some of those cases okay and
in other cases they may I've had I've
heard from kids that the parents say
don't tell them all about this personal
stuff and there's some therapy and
framing behavior on behalf of the
parents or they're not doing their
homework they come to group but they
don't do their homework but expect
Johnny to do their home so I'm giving
you extreme version as many of the
parents I work with are absolutely
fabulous highly motivated and wonderful
but I want parents and families to be
aware of the vmail
gauge in at times some therapy in
different behavior and of course the
therapists ourselves can be known to
engage in therapy and different
behaviors what are those coming late to
session not returning phone calls in a
timely fashion being a little to change
oriented or to acceptance oriented and
imbalanced from a dbt perspective
therapeutically so there's a lot of
things that we're keeping an eye on and
I want my kids to know that I am I could
equally engage in TI be as you and if it
happens we have to address it and only
after that will be then get into quality
of life interfering behaviors which is
what most people think therapy is about
the depression relationship challenges
substance use and so forth and while I'm
trying to decrease targets one two and
three we're trying to increase all the
behavioral skills that they're going to
learn in skills group all right now so
that was just me trying to orient him
and we can certainly talk more about I
wanted to just take a clip that
highlighted what I how I described in
like I said and very compressed fashion
the modes of the treatment to him I what
I didn't I cut off as a little bit of
the fact that I have a therapist
consultation meeting where I meet with
the skills trainers and we talk about
how to best help him and his family and
I also told them about some family
sessions as needed just so you know
though in adolescent DBT after five or
six months of treatment and now the
randomized trials are four months but
some of the work that Jill and I put
together now have skills that kind of
cook Phil a six-month curriculum that
has that that model is yet to be
researched yet so we have to see at the
six-month level if it's more or less
effective but we have a graduate group
and my feeling is if you're going to
work with kids who have a multitude of
issues it's great to get some kind of
remission of these symptoms if you will
or behaviors or problems but undoubtedly
after only four or five or six months if
they've been dealing with these things
for quite a while there's going to be a
chance of high degree of relapse if you
don't have some kind of maintenance or
continuation phase of treatment so that
brings us to the graduate group which is
the highlight of my week clinically when
i get to see teenagers who have been
working on kind of acquiring the skills
in the multifamily group and now putting
them into practice where they consult to
their peers about problems that are
having in the wit during the
eek and they have the interpersonal
validation and support and feedback
about how to be more effective in
reaching their long term goals so that's
going on as well this is a shameless
shameless plug for the manual that Jill
and I just came out with but I'm
referring to the skill so I felt like it
was a reasonable excuse to at least show
you the picture before I talk about some
of the skills that are in the book in
the book and this is the kind of
curriculum like I am alluding to that is
about 24 weeks long so we have two weeks
of orientation of mindfulness and then
four weeks of distress tolerance two
weeks of orientation of mindfulness
where new people can enter the group
four weeks of middle of walking middle
path and so on okay now I already talked
about some of the middle path additions
or skills and so on I don't need to go
spend too much time on it these are some
of the dilemmas that we've identified
that I've alluded to in terms of teens
and families getting polarized and
teaching them how to find a more of a
middle path and in terms of middle path
in addition to teaching them dialectical
dilemmas and dialectical thinking and
acting we also talked about teaching
principles of behaviorism and learning
that we talk I mentioned earlier and we
all Jill rattusses graduate student
Bevan campbell let us study or extra
dissertation on the acceptability of the
walking the middle path skills right so
dialectics behavior ism and validation
and we took 50 parents and teens taken
from the our Bronx clinic and montefiore
as well as Jill rattusses group practice
and use the mixed methods approach and
the results were that that these
families found these skills highly
acceptable to both teens and parents and
of all the 27 skills that we do teach
they found the middle path skills to be
ranked most highly and most helpful and
the skill of validation itself was
considered most beneficial skill among
all are 27 skills with reinforcements
close behind and if you don't believe me
ask oprah winfrey on our 25th
anniversary year show she said of all
the skills that she's learned
not DBT that is but of life skills
validation was the most compelling
important in her in her mind as well you
don't have to believe me Oprah really at
my place is this true yeah so so I
thought she said that some of the
additional skills though that that we've
added to the manual and you know when
you're working with kids who whose
emotion dysregulation so intense and
they're just trying to out it's in the
ocean and they're floating around and
their head is bobbing and they're just
trying to get air and stay alive if you
will it's very hard for them to kind of
be goal-oriented they're in crisis
survival mode right there just barely
staying afloat so it's hard for them to
be clear on a week-to-week basis what am
i working toward and so one of the
things that what I think was missing
that we we eventually added to this
manual was helping these kids gradually
as the dysregulation comes down have a
greater awareness of their wise mind
goals and values and priorities you know
is my is my value or goal to be a leader
is it to be healthy is it to be part of
a group and kind of having them find
their wise mind around that to then
inform what are what are some of the
goals and things were going to be
working toward in treatment another
thing that we realized working with
families is that we had all these
Pleasant activities for kids to work on
separately parents you go have fun by
yourself and we realized that part of
the problem is that there's a gradual
kind of divide and they're kind of
having engaging in separate tracks and
we wanted to kind of prescribe some teen
and parent shared Pleasant activities
both for their own each of their own
emotion regulation strategies with under
which that's the module but also for
obviously enhanced positive family
interaction so we that is a big part of
the emotion regulation peace with the
teens and families and prescribing fun
prescribing pleasure you know they're
like I don't have time for that I don't
I understand but you made in your
appointment calendar time for this group
how do you do that while you put it in
your calendar as Alec Miller group good
okay now I want you to
find time and put into your calendar and
that's your pleasurable activity time
either alone or with Johnny but you have
to schedule it it will never ever happen
ever unless you build that in so we got
to schedule that there's some lot of the
kids are depressed anted onic and they
are not going to do this without some
major behavioral activation and
scheduling turns out that many of the
kids we see also have major sleep
impairment and there's no there's it's
not a coincidence that the sleep
impaired sleep coincides with mood
episodes and increases in self-injury
and suicidal behavior and so we've been
targeting that you know it used to feel
like such a lower target oh just a
little sleep problem you know we have so
many bigger fish to fry but if we can
deal with this as a major vulnerability
factor towards more depression more self
injuring more suicide so now it's on our
diary card and we're giving them
prescription for 12 steps of better
sleep good sleep hygiene and everyone in
this room knows how much your food
affects your mood and so we're doing a
lot on nutrition and healthy eating and
balanced eating so I'm aware my time I'm
trying to figure out the things I want
to highlight in the remaining time I
have there's you know I've alluded to
this but the importance of involving
families not only in the skills training
group but also in teaching family skills
and a lot of the parents we work with
have some very good skills but when they
themselves get dysregulated it's very
hard to apply those skills to that child
or adolescent in the moment so we're
going to review those skills strengthen
those skills and then bring them into
family sessions where we're going to do
some invivo coaching and sometimes we'll
do a family chain analysis where we
might have a teenager who's engaging in
some kind of problematic behavior and
i'll do the adolescent behavioural chain
and then alone then i bring mom or dad
in and say I understand you were
involved in the situation with Johnny
that we have to figure out what happens
so we can kind of avert this problem
next next time so let's get your chain
and so Johnny listens as mom or dad
presents their chain and we kind of see
where some of the problematic links in
this family chain are and come up with
some solution analyses for both parties
so they can avert that outcome and have
a better trajectory in their next
interaction so it takes some slow
tedious sometimes painful sometimes
intense emotional discussion as we tease
this out and then prescribe
collaboratively some solutions to avert
that problem for next time so so I want
to spend a few minutes talking about DBT
and non mental health setting schools
and medic and those for medically
non-adherent youth and I think the most
the folks in this audience have we been
doing DBT downstream for a long time so
you know outpatient DBT iop residential
you know impatient that's all good but
what about this notion of starting DBT
further upstream so about 10 years ago
or so myself and some colleagues started
doing some school based DBT a health
teacher up and ulster counter County
asked me whether I could give her some
curriculum and she could do it in her
health class because these kids in
austere County had major substance
problems and depression and she knew she
was not a clinician she was a health
teacher but just had a sense that they
needed some tools and she was teaching
all this curriculum for health but
realizing that you know it was kind of
very disparate and she thought if she
could give them some life skills in
health class at under light on was
underlying some of the other curriculum
maybe maybe just maybe that would have
some in you know in effect we didn't get
any IRB approvals there was no research
formally conducted in that setting but
that's where my mind started going in
terms of doing some school based DBT
then some other psychologists in the
Westchester County community where I
live that said what about doing we have
these kids that are really kind of when
we call frequent flyers in the schools
that end up in the principal's office
getting sent out of district and we
don't know what to do can you teach us
DBT in a more comprehensive way what you
do on your outpatient setting can we do
that in schools I'm like I don't know
but let's see if we can try and so we
started doing that and so there's kind
of a two-pronged approach one is that
kind of more targeted what I call
secondary and tertiary prevention
interventions for elementary middle
school in high school and those are for
the kids who have multiple problems who
are already showing up in front of
administration CSE meetings then I don't
classified and then there's others who
were thinking about DBT on a more
Universal class-wide primary prevention
model and for the comprehensive DBT
we've been using my the manual Jill and
I did and more the formal DBT there's a
some a program called steps DBT steps a
gym Mazel is masa Jill ratha sand I
elizabeth murphy have a book called DBT
skills training for emotional problem
solving for adolescents and this I will
tell you about so I just want to give
you what i think is an interesting
conceptual point which is in schools you
know the expression WTF it's called
waiting to fail waiting to fail so
waiting to fail is that these kids do
not get help until they're having really
struggling right so so there's not
there's not a lot of prevention in
schools and so once they get have
problems then they get classified and
then they get these resources and so
what we're trying to figure out is is
there a way to kind of embed some of
these life school life skills in schools
to help with a late elementary middle
school kind of learning how to be
mindful learning how to tolerate
distress learning how to regulate
emotions learning how to be in to
personally effective when but you know
pre puberty puberty and then before
their mid to late adolescence when they
end up at tier for adolescent outpatient
services residential treatment and
hospitalization so can we get it in
earlier and so Jim mazza said what about
it a universal population can we just
get it into classroom settings and and
so that's where the steps a model has
come as kind of coming in I know there's
some folks here in the Stanford School
District I don't know where Jenkins is
she in here yeah there they are so you
guys are there so they're going to be
doing it in a local high school and in
Connecticut and there and the kids are
going to get credit right for
participating in learning these life
skills in high school which is wonderful
so there's kind of different models
where we're going to do that
and then there's a more school-based
mental health approach for those who
need more than just from a prevention
standpoint but they need individual
counseling they need coaching during the
day that you know so that so the mental
health team and the school guidance
counselor and the special educators are
meeting on a weekly team meeting so they
have team meetings in school they have
all the modes and functions of standard
DBT in a school setting they're getting
coaching they have team meetings they
have skills training they have
individual counseling so that's going on
and that's happening I just here's a
list of some of the local school
districts here and and and on the west
coast a little bit we're doing either
comprehensive or steps a Francesca did
this actually in New Haven we published
a paper about five years ago in a local
school of the Yale ease kids right was
it the Newton delhi's kids and so they
you know they were a very special unique
group and the professor's private school
no not yellow School private school but
they were very specific group Erica
Lander and some of my friends from the
Bronx did something at ps8 elementary
school at mono fewer so we've done in
different kinds of settings elementary
middle and high school why we why the
administrators and the school districts
are kind of saying hey what this is this
seems useful what are the administrators
and schools care about dollars and they
find that they send a kid out of
Westchester High School into a
specialized educational setting it's
about a hundred thousand dollars for the
treatment education and busing so they
say well maybe we'll spend a few bucks
having you train our staff then and
that's seriously how the administration
thinks now in addition we have some
interesting help in terms of pointing
out what we can reduce their ER visits
psychiatric and mental medical
hospitalizations you know as 20 years
I've been spending in the Bronx and mono
fewer that we have the second busiest ER
in the country and the ER is overloaded
with whom kids from the local schools in
why because they somehow either wrote
something that expressed some suicidal
thinking have a superficial cut
something where the school's mandate is
you do
pesco you do not collect hundred two
hundred you go to the emergency room if
anything sounds self-harming so these
kids now are removed from the school
have to be you know disrobed put into a
gown monitored by security have to be
then evaluated in the middle of the
night family has to leave work then they
have to be ushered to some psychiatric
hospital it is a very dysfunctional
system that we need to do better and
being able to help these schools do
better job assessing risk managing this
in the school system and so we're
working on that with the local schools
i'm talking about now i know i can tell
seth is getting antsy and is going to be
coming up here momentarily some data
from the schools so preliminary very
very preliminary rough at data from this
local high school in ardsley they found
that just doing this after six months
those kids who they were treating with
comprehensive DBT had reduced referrals
to the assistant principals reductions
in cutting class reductions in detention
to suspensions again compared to the
prior six months and then anecdotal
reductions in depression anxiety and
nssi the challenge is the school culture
is like an emergency room they will
respond to crises but lower level
problems they don't attend to so from a
behavioral perspective it is pretty much
a disaster so we have to get buy-in from
upper administration to not over respond
and overreact to every every problematic
behavior and and not wait till it's Code
Red and so I've had a patient in my
practice who I was working with who was
treated who was also seen at the school
of social worker at the local high
school and she was really out of control
seen daily but then as she was getting
better the school social worker saw her
weekly and then even in the weekly
sessions that sometimes get interrupted
because the principal would bring
another student in who is more highly
dysregulated and my patient got kicked
out of the school social workers office
and she's like it's almost like I have
to raise the ante to get some attention
around here I said it does feel that way
we got to work on that we can't have
this school systems operating in this
way so all right steps a I'll just tell
you real quick sorry let me you the
structure for step say is that there
there are 30 lessons they
50 minute periods you can kind of go you
know teacher curriculum step 1 open your
binder step to take out your pencils
step 3 read this and we're going to
teach you in a much more didactic
teacher general ed teacher kind of way
and that's that covers all of the
domains of standard DBT and use a lot of
the skills handouts that Jill and I
developed and so that there's a teacher
manual and a student workbook and
there's more we can talk about the Dalai
Lama of course says that when you're
educating the minds of our youth we must
not forget to educate their hearts the
last thing I want to say about other
adaptations of dbt which means some of
you might find interesting is that a
former intern of mine becky hashem now
Becky Louis realized that working in the
Children's Hospital of mono fewer there
were so many kids with chronic medical
illnesses that were non-adherent and
what DBT is uniquely good at is getting
non-adherent individuals to be more
adherent with XY and z behaviors so we
decided to develop a sixth or seventh
session adaptation of dbt for kids with
chronic medical illness started with
kids with chronic kidney disease who
were essentially blacklisted from
transplant because they were so
non-adherent the doctors like we're not
treating that kid so we gave we gave
these kids this intervention and six out
of the seven kids who got this brief
intervention gap got back on transplant
list and transplanted which was very
lovely so we said what about adapting it
for diabetic youth that's a big problem
so now we have some funding to do that
study and we're underway looking at that
so I in some I think what we need to do
is publish the results from all the
existing randomized trials with
adolescents including the large one from
UCLA in University of Washington you
know I was talking earlier with Carla
about you know I was I was I had the
privilege of getting trained by Anthony
Bateman and Peter Fonda he recently a
mental ization based therapy Jill and I
had a good time going up there together
and learning from the experts and
undoubtedly you know they have a lot of
overlap and there's differences and I
think for some kids they don't respond
as well a dbt you might add some mental
ization maybe with some kids don't
respond well the metallization add some
DBT and what's one of the unique factors
common factors different factors and can
they complement each other there's
research there it's got a battle that
will be in the next step because we are
have an NBT randomized trial that shows
that it's very promising with some of
our kids is DBT skills training alone
effective can you just do skills
training without individual has to be
done is DBT effective for children
younger than 13 Francesca is answering
that has questions and then looking at
this in a much more rigorous research
way in schools I'm very passionate about
the school piece you know for years it
felt like without a lessons and makes
sense you know anecdotally we think we
know it know it works but now we need
data and we got data same thing with
schools it feels like it makes sense
teachers are hungry for it psychologists
and the schools are hungry for general
ed teachers some of them are even
getting hungry for it we got to research
that and and then obviously for chronic
medical illnesses we have to see if
that's working and we have some data on
that but finally can we help prevent
borderline personality disorder through
some Universal skills classes can there
be ways of teaching these life skills at
younger ages fourth grade fifth grade
sixth grade and acquiring and practicing
these skills just like they learn
English math social studies why not can
they not learn life skills anyone please
thank you thank you so much thank you so
much talent
thank you so much i like am I on is this
on yeah you are okay we have a couple of
questions relating to some of the
dialectics you referred to a few came in
asking for help distinguishing between
BPD features and normative adolescent
acting out or fun or some of the things
that are typical of adolescents from
what's BPD features so what what's
normal adolescent behavior meaning you
know some some problems of I dental
mental identity care relationships
effectively ability that's adolescents
it's a very tough as you all heard the
question I mean my my working kind of
way of thinking about it is if you can
have all kinds of pretty egregious
things happen adolescence but only when
it becomes impairment in functioning do
I say that it would warrant more of a
diagnostic application of BPD or
whatever other diagnosis it is so
adolescence is a time of experimenting
doing some very unthoughtful non mindful
things and and risky things I would say
but if it starts to impair functioning
obviously that's when you have to think
about more of a diagnostic picture oh
and also different dialectic would you
explain the dialectic of forcing
autonomy and fostering dependence yeah
what's that so fostering fostering
dependence versus forcing autonomy
fostering dependence sometimes you'll
see where a kid has a problem in a
classroom let's say you know middle
schooler has a problem with a peer or
teacher fostering dependence would be
the parent swoops in tells the
administration of the school I want that
my child removed I don't like the way
this teacher or students dealing with my
child I want that problem fixed the
child does nothing to solve that problem
is just kind of at the whim of the
helicopter follow so that's fostering
dependence forcing autonomy though is
when you have a problem and and you have
an adolescent who's struggling with
something and the parents sometimes say
Your Honor this is you baby this you're
on your own this is either your therapy
this is your problem solve oh you got
yourself pregnant okay well it's time to
maybe find your own place and and it's
kind of kind of
being them prematurely into their
adulthood or more responsibility than
they're ready to handle with that
without adequate coaching and
supervision and parenting those are the
those are the extreme poles obviously we
want to move them to the middle we have
a couple of questions about engaging
individuals there's one about what do
you do if the person is resistant to the
adolescence resistant at what point
would you terminate with it with a
client who's refusing the gold standard
treatment for his disorder there's
another one about the individual
becoming passive maintaining a role of
passivity going it's hospitalization
again so it's too about engaging a so in
terms of passivity in terms of engaged
in wanted preferring a hospital I mean
one of the challenges I think we have as
a healthcare system and as families and
caretakers and therapists is how to make
their wow I'm getting very loud you how
to make their outpatient life at home
and a school and a treatment more
reinforcing if you will than impatient
and you know I was consulted to Bronx
Psychiatric Center whether it's a state
hospital and they the staff looks at me
like they're amazed and why they would
that someone's been there for 10 years
why wouldn't they want to get out of a
state facility and go back to the
community well some of these adults in
the state facility have established
families with their staff their peers in
three square meals a day and if they go
out there it's not they don't get all
that so we have to think creatively
about how to make their outpatient
experience better than their impatient
and we have to make their impatient
experiences a little less good I got to
say I've been consulting in some places
I've worked in some places where you
know they go into seclusion the quiet
room you know these teenagers are there
and then these have these 20-year old
attractive men and women fanning the
magazine section what which magazine
would you like and what fruit what food
would you like right now and and you
know so it's like you know you want a
mani and a pedi while we're at it so
it's so so it so we that's almost too
good and we have to dial that back and
anything else to add on the person who's
refusing to do the gold standard and is
there a point when you would terminate
because they're refusing
you know there's some kids we've seen
who've been in pre treatment for a lot
longer they're just not you know and and
and it's I wish I don't know who they
are at the outset sometimes I think
people who be highly committed turn out
not to be and those who seem apparently
unenthused get engaged quickly so I mean
we could probably do there's a little
research to be done in that arena but I
I'm an optimist and the glasses always
have full for me so I'm rarely thrown in
the towel prematurely but at a certain
point if in discussion with the family
and the teenager and the treatment my
treatment team we deem it you know this
is not effective or and where the
behaviors are getting worse and
dangerous well then we have to think
about alternative levels of care but
what they often get to us it's kind of
the last stop before they send them out
are there DBT components that are not a
good fit for adolescents given their
stage of development other DBT
components that are not good for their
stage of development not that I mean I
think the group is a natural for them
right with their peers I think what's
not less natural as peers and parents
and they they don't necessarily get
excited about that at first blush and
they say don't make me do it don't make
me do it and so that's a common response
when when we introduced the multifamily
format so that's not as natural for them
to talk about whatever issues they have
in front of their parents in a multiple
family format but so I think it's a
little awkward but I think it's
effective in helping them see that their
parents are also struggling with some
issues that there's other kids and
there's a universality to it that the
kids can learn from other kids the
parents can get support from other
parents so I still like the modality
even though it's not as naturally
inclined for them probably this person
points out that hormones estrogen
testosterone changes strongly affect
emotions do you see a role for education
regarding biology for teens and adults
in family DBT I i mean i think there's
there's definitely room for that and i
think we talked i mean certainly
individual sessions we talked about some
of that personally and privately with
some of the kids i think it could be
added to the curriculum as normal kind
of development they should get that in
their health curriculum if they're if
they're going to it
so I'm not against it I don't know how
much we need to amplify it this person
speaks to the prime texting is the
primary form of teen communication and
what advice you might have for BPD teens
for how to adjust their use of texting
to be more mindful less impulsive
anything like that if you can't beat
them you join them I for many years I
was like I'm not texting I am not
texting my kids I am NOT my patients I'm
not doing it it turns out that they have
voicemail phobia they have regular phone
phobias they don't they don't they they
have such familiarity and comfort with
this that I will I myself will text them
for non-life-threatening coaching
situations and at the same time I want
them to practice being unplugged during
my sessions during groups and hopefully
at other designated times where they can
practice living life more mindful e
without multitasking between their
texting and they're talking and they you
know I mean you go to a urinal and you
pull up next to somebody and they're
texting and urine I mean you wherever
you go it's universal it's a problem
across society so I don't blame the kids
or the parents in the room we're all
modeling that for our kids so it's not
like a kid problem let's be clear guys
the adults with us we're guilty to do
teachers and students attend the school
trainings together like parents and the
teens in the outpatient say that one
more to teachers and students ever
attend the school trainings together
similarly to the parents and teens in
the outpatient so so yeah I mean some of
the teachers the students in the schools
have teachers in the room whether it's
the school psychologist doing it with
one of the teachers so they'll get
exposure to the teachers and the kids
getting it together yeah how actually
I'm going to go back to that one or do
the teachers also are they pushed to
learn the skills in front of the
adolescents use their skills all night
any of that sort of thing not that we
haven't gotten to that stage although
that's an interesting thought it's an
interesting thought we have not gotten
the teachers doing their homework per se
like that and sharing it but that's an
interesting idea yeah how do you involve
the parents when doing DBT in the
schools do kids continue regular
outpatient treatment so some of the kids
in DVT in schools have individual and
can
group at school there's also these team
meetings at school and then the parents
will get invited in like a gnarly high
school for example to come in once a
month for like an hour not 90 minute
kind of skill review so they can get to
hear what the kids have being are being
taught weekly so they come in that way
at PSA Elementary School in the Bronx
we'd have a the kids fourth and fifth
grade kids in a skills group and then
the parents would come in you know late
late after mid afternoon or late
afternoon for a parent skills adapted
version for them there's different
formats but we do like to get the
parents and into the schools whenever
humanly possible it's more challenging
of course a lot of obstacles to that all
right thank you and the final questions
I have thank you dr. Miller Alec the
final questions i have i've got some
broad questions about DBT that i could
put to the panel i'd like to do that
transition to this last part of our
program day invite our speakers up to
the to the stage to have a seat at the
table there a microphone set up Alec if
you'd have a seat thank you very much